6 25 on your monday morning here's
something that should not be driving you
crazy there's a twist on the timing of
traffic signals
in henderson have you noticed anything
different about the timing of the
signals on eastern from pebble
just north of the 215 all the way south
past saint gross parkway to sun ridge
heights parkway
well the regional transportation
commission along with the city of
henderson and clark county been tweaking
the timing of the 14 signals along that
stretch
instead of traditional timers or demand
activated signals in slower hours
the pilot project involves what's called
asct that stands for adaptive
signal control technology according to
the rtc
signals with asct are supposed to react
to changing traffic conditions to
provide solutions in real time
strategically placed sensors collect and
feed data into a controller
which implements signal timing updates
based on that real-time data
the project started back in october
scheduled to run through march of this
year i'd be curious to hear your
thoughts in the meantime
please buckle up drive carefully and put
down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com